[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقتنا النهارده
بتكون اول حلقه ان شاء الله في سلسله
بعنوان العالم هذا الاسبوع عباره عن نشره
بنحاول نستعرض فيها اهم ما حدث في الايام
الماضيه السبعه ايام اللي فاتت ونعرض الى
ما قاله اكبر الكتاب
والمراقبين في الاحداث الرئيسيه خلال
الفتره اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها ونستمر في
هذه السلسله اذا اعجبتكم وده هعرفه من
تعليق
حضراتكم الحدث الرئيسي اللي فرض نفسه هذا
الاسبوع الحقيقه هو في الشرق الاوسط مش كل
مره انا عاوز اتكلم على الشرق الاوسط
المفروض ان احنا نتكلم على احداث متنوعه
من خلال هذه السلسله لكن الشرق الاوسط فرض
نفسه على كل وسائل الاعلام امريكا
اللاتينيه افريقيا اسيا فضلا طبعا عن
اوروبا والولايات
المتحده الحدث الرئيسي خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه او الاسبوع الماضي واللي
شغل كل وسائل الاعلام هو اتساع الصراع بعد
7 اكتوبر
2023 بحيث اصبحنا نقترب كل يوم من حرب
محتمله بين ايران من ناحيه والولايات
المتحده وحلفائها من ناحيه اخرى ما هو
الجديد خلال الاسبوع الماضي في 3 فبراير
الجاري اعلن الامريكان عن قصف نحو 85 هدف
للحرس الثوري الايراني والميليشيات
التابعه له في سبع مواقع في غرب العراق
وشرق سوريا لماذا لان الامريكان يتهمون
ايران
وحلفائها بشن هجوم على قواتها الموجوده او
قواتهم الموجوده في موقع حدودي في شمال
شرق الاردن بالقرب من الحدود السوريه في
28 يناير الماضي هذا الهجوم تصعيد خطير في
المواجهه الدائره بين امريكا
وايران ومن يوم
7 اكتوبر بدات الهجمات تزيد على القوات
الامريكيه بشكل مكثف جدا وتقديرات
البنتاجون انه في
151 هجوم على الاق قل على القوات
الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط من يوم 13
اكتوبر تحديدا وحتى 23 يناير اشمعنى 23
يناير ده تاريخ التصريح اكيد جءت بعده
هجمات اخرى لكن كان هجوم 28 يناير اللي
نفذته ملشيات مواليه لايران الوحيد اللي
اسفر عن ايراق الدماء امريكيه وطبعا ايراق
الدماء امريكيه هو خط احمر لواشنطن كما ان
مهاجم العمق الايراني خط احمر
لطهران تاملوا معي كيف اتسعت دائره العنف
في الشرق الاوسط منذ هجوم 7 اكتوبر يعني
هجوم 28 يناير ده ادى لهجوم 3 فبراير لكن
الهجومين كلهم هما جزءا من سلسله طويله من
الفعل ورد الفعل على خمس ساحات هي العراق
وسوريا واليمن ولبنان فضلا عن غزه التي
منها انطلقت الشراره الاولى في 7 اكتوبر
2023 مثلا وانا بدي مثلا لانه الفعل ورد
الفعل كتير سلسله طويله بتكلم على الامثله
الرئيسه في 25 ديسمبر
2023 قتلت غاره اسرائيليه الجنرال
الايراني سيد رادي موسوي في دمشق وقسف
الامريكان مواقع لكتا كتائب حزب الله
العراقيه ردا على ايه على استهداف القوات
الامريكيه من جانب هذه الكتائب في اربيل
في 2 يناير اغتلت اسرائيل السيد صارح
العاروري نائب زعيم او نائب رئيس حركه
حماس في بيروت في 3 يناير تعرضت مدينه
كارمان الايرانيه لتفجيرات
ا خطيره جدا استهدفت مواطنين تجمعوا
لاحياء الذكرى الرابعه لاغتيال الجنرال
قاسم سليماني قائد فيلق القدس التابع
للحرس الثوري اللي اغتالته امريكا في 3
يناير
2020 الهجمات الارهابيه اسفرت عن مقتر ما
يقرب من 90 مواطنا ايرانيا وهي واحده من
اكثر الهجمات
دمويه في تاريخ الجمهوريه الايرانيه
الاسلاميه اي منذ العام
1979 في 4 يناير اغتالت الولايات المتحده
قيادي اظن اسمه ابو التقى وهو قيادي في
ميليشيا حركه النجباء العراقيه في بغداد ل
قناعه الامريكان ان له دورا في هجمات على
اهداف امريكيه بطلب من الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه
ايران ثم شنت الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ضربات جويه يوميه على الحوثيين او انصار
الله في اليمن بدايه من 12 يناير وطبعا رد
عليها الحوثيون
باستهداف السفن والمصالح الامريكيه
والبريطانيه في البحر
الاحمر ايران ردا على هجوم 3 يناير قامت
يوم 15 و16 يناير بتوجيه ضربات على لاث
جبهات استهدفت فلول داعش في سوريا ده وفقا
للروايه الايرانيه فلول داعش في سوريا سيا
وجماعات كرديه في العراق
وجماعات بلوش انفصاليه في
باكستان العراق وسوريا ما عندهمش القدره
يردوا على ايران لكن باكستان ردت على
الضربات الايرانيه على اراضيها بضربات
مماثله في العمق
الايراني في 20 يناير قتلت غاره جويه
اسرائيليه خمسه اعضاء بارزين في الحرس
الثوري الايراني في دمشق وفي اليوم نفسه
اطلقت ميليشيا شيعيه عراقيه طبعا تابعه
لايران وابلا من الصواريخ على قاعده الاسد
الامريكيه في العراق ثم وصلت تصعيد ذروته
بهجوم 28 يناير و3 فبراير هذا التصعيد
الذي يزداد سخونه هو اكثر ما يشغل كل دول
العالم هذا الاسبوع لا توجد صحيفه او موقع
واحد كبير الا وتضمن عناوين تشير الى هذا
التصعيد وتحذر من عواقبه التي قد تاخذ
الجميع رغما عنهم لحرب واسعه ولكن كل كاتب
تناول هذا التصعيد الخطير من زاويه توماس
فريدمان بعد هجمات 28 يناير كتب في تحديدا
31 يناير مقالا مهما جدا
بعنوان عقيده او مبدا بين قوسين يقصد
استراتيجيه يعني بيضا للشرق الاوسط تتشكل
وهي استراتيجيه مهمه جدا ده هو اللي بيقول
مش انا يعني في هذا المقال عرض توماس
فريدمان واذكركم ان توماس فريدمان ليس
صحفيا يعني مثل الغالبيه العظمى من
الصحفيين الامريكان هو صحفي استثنائي بايه
لما اقول انه صحفي مهم يعني عنده مصادر
مهمه الذي يجعل الصحفي يختلف عن عن غيره
من المهتمين بالراي العام وبشان العام هو
امتلاكه لعدد مهمه من المصادر كلما زادت
مصادرك فانت صحفي افضل وطبعا لانه عنده
مصادر كثيره ومنها البيت الابيض وخصوصا في
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن الذي يدعوه الى
البيت الابيض ويقرا مقالاته ويصغي اليه
وكمان توماس فريدمان ينقل كثيرا من رسائل
الرئيس جو بايدن عبر مقالاته على كل
الاحوال توماس فريدمان بيقول هناك
استراتيجيه للبيت الابيض من ثلاث محاور
وان الرئيس جو بايدن بدا بالفعل في
تنفيذها ولكن يجب ان يستمر فيها بشكل حاسم
حتى لا تتطور الازمه الحاليه في الشرق
الاوسط الى كارثه
شامله تعريفه للكارثه الشامله بالنسبه
للسيد يعني توماس فريدمان انه هتدي الى
تعزيز نف فوذ ايران وتعزل اسرائيل وتهمش
قدره امريكا على التاثير في الاحداث بشكل
يدعو
للاسى وبيقول سيكون لهذه العقيده او
المبدا او الاستراتيجي هو الكلمه اللي
استخدمها بالانجليزي الكترين ف ترجموها زي
ما انتم عاوزين ثلاثه
مسارات المسار الاول هو اتخاذ موقف قوي
وحازم تجاه ايران بما في ذلك الخيار
العسكري الح حاسم ضد و وكلاء ايران ردا
على استهداف الجنود والمصالح الامريكيه في
المنطقه ده واحد
اثنين من محاور استراتيجيه او عقيده بايدن
في الشرق الاوسط لاحتواء الازمه المتصاعده
هو اطلاق مبادره امريكيه غير مسبوقه لدعم
اقامه دوله فلسطينيه الان دوله فلسطينيه
منزوعه السلاح في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
والتي لن تظهر ابدا الى العلن او الوجود
الا بعد ان يطور الفلسطينيون طبعا بدعم
امريكي مجموعه من المؤسسات والقدرات
الامنيه ذات المصداقيه لضمان ان هذه
الدوله ستكون قادره على الاستمرار والحياه
فابل يعني ولكنها لن تكون ابدا قادره على
تهديد امن
اسرائيل وكشف عن ان مسؤولي اداره بايدن
يتشاورون الان مع خبراء داخل وخارج
الاداره الامريكيه حول الاشكال المختلفه
التي قد تكون عليها هذه الدوله الفلسطينيه
وشكل الاعتراف الامريكي بها اما المسار
الثالث في استراتيجيه بايدن وفقا لتوماس
فريدمان فهو تحالف امني امريكي موسع مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تحديدا وان هذا
التحالف قد يشمل تطبيعا سعوديا مع اسرائيل
اذا كانت الحكومه الاسرائيليه مستعده
لتبني عمليه دبلوماسيه تؤدي الى دوله
فلسطينيه منزوعه السلاح بقياده السلطه
الفلسطينيه بعد
اصلاحها اذا حدث ذلك فان عقيده بايدن او
مبدا بايدن يمكن ان يكون اكبر اعاده او
تغيير للمشهد في منطقه الشرق الاوسط منذ
معاهده كاب ديفيد
1979 ده كلام توماس فريدمان وهو كلام انا
اعتقد انه مهم
على الاقل اقتنعنا به لم نقتنع به يمكن
تنفيذه لا يمكن تنفيذه على الاقل هو مهم
في انه بيخلينا نفهم العقل الامريكي
الحاكم الان بيفكر ازاي في واشنطن بوست
بتاريخ 1 فبراير كتب ديفيد اجناش اس مقالا
مهما في نفس الاتجاه عن التصور الامريكي
لانهاء حرب غزه والسيطره على التصعيد
الخطير في الشرق الاوسط ديفيد جنشس صحفي
وكاتب مهم زي توماس فريدمان لكنه اقل شهره
على الاقل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط لكنه
ايضا بيتمتع بمصادر قويه جدا مش بس في
الولايات المتحده ومع النخبه الحاكمه ولكن
مع كثير من زعماء العالم وعنده عاده يعني
انا كنت بتواصل معاه في فتره من الفترات
انه ياتي مثلا الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط و
يكون عنده جوله كده يلتقي فيها كثير من
القيادات والزعامات والغريبه انه لا ينشر
عاده يعني تفاصيل لقاءاته مع هذه الزعامات
ويكتفي باشاره صغيره في مقالته المنتظمه
في واشنطن بوست
مقاله حمل عنوان الولايات المتحده تتحرك
بقوه نحو لحظه الحقيقه في الشرق الاوسط
خلاصه
المقال ان التصور الامريكي لانهاء حرب غزه
واعاده تشكيل الشرق الاوسط بيرتكس في
الاساس
على قبول السعوديه للتطبيع مع اسرائيل
اجناش اس بيقول ان وزير الخارجيه انتوني
بلينكن خلال زيارته الاخيره هو كتب الكلام
ده في 1 فبراير الزياره الاخيره للشرق
الاوسط بدات خلال اليومين الماضيين هو
بيقول ان هذه
الزياره سوف تركز على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه املا في ان يجدد ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
جديته في التطبيع مع اسرا اذا وفقط اذا ده
تعبيره هو مش انا اللي قايله انهت اسرائيل
الحرب في غزه والتزمت بانشاء دوله
فلسطينيه على
اراضي غزه وقطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه
اثنين اذا اطمان بلينكن الى الموقف
السعودي من التطبيع المشروط سيكون قادرا
على تنفيذ التصور
الامريكي تصور اداره بايدن تالي وفقا
لديفيد
اجناش تقدم اداره الرئيس بايدن العاجزه عن
الضغط على نتنياهو لخفض حده الصراع اللي
ممكن يورت امريكا في حرب لا
تريدها تقدم لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
عرضا لا يمكن لائتلاف المتطرف قبوله
سياسيا هو نتنياهو بيحكم من خلال
ائتلاف الائتلاف ده هم ما عندهمش مانع
يتعاملوا مع نتنياهو اعتباره السياسي في
النهايه ايا كان تشدده هو سياسي
بريماتيور وغيرهم الاداره الامريكيه لا
تريد التعامل معهم باعتبارهم متطرفين لا
يصلحون للعمل السياسي فهي عاوزه تعمل ايه
تقدم لنتنياهو عرضا لا يمكن لهؤلاء
المتطرفين اللي بيشاركوا نتنياهو الحكومه
ان يقبلوه ولكن لا يمكن لنتنياهو السياسي
البرجماتي الراغب في ان يظل يعني ان يكون
له
ا مكانه مهمه في السياسه الاسرائيليه الان
وبعد ان يغادر السلطه ان يرفضه ايه هو
العرض ده العرض ده هو التطبيع مع السعوديه
الجائزه الكبرى الان في مقابل انهاء الحرب
والتفاوض على اقامه دوله فلسطينيه ملحوظه
مهمه احنا اتكلمنا على العرض السعودي ده
مرات عديده قبل كده سوف اضع لكم روابط
طريقه التفكير السعودي لكن ملحوظه سريعه
اذكركم انه للعرض السعودي جانب اخر عباره
عن مطالب سعوديه من الولايات المتحده يعني
العرض السعودي ده له شقين شق يتعلق
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه اعاده اللي هو وقف
الحرب اعمار غزه البدء في التفاوض على
القضيه الفلسطينيه وله شق اخر عباره عن
مطالب سعوديه من الولايات المتحده قلناها
مرات عديده اتفاقيه امنيه
موسعه تنع في ظلها السعوديه بضمانات امنيه
تنعم بها الدول الاعضاء في حلف شمال
الاطلسي يعني يعني حمايه امريكيه او غربيه
كامله
اثنين اسلحه متطوره تحصل عليها السعوديه
بدون اي فيتو من الاداره الامريكيه لان
الفيتو ده بينطبق تقريبا على معظم دول
العالم ما عدا عدد محدود وعلى راسهم
اسرائيل وثلاثه طبعا بناء برنامج نووي
متطور على راض السعوديه
سلمي فهذا هو العرض ممكن نتنياهو يقبل
العرض لكن اعضاء حكومته يرفضوا العرض اللي
يتضمن وقف اطلاق النار وه يتضمن موافقه
على اقامه دوله فلسطينيه لا يمكن هم
يوافقوا على هذا الكلام يتفكك الائتلاف
ويبحث نتنياهو عن حلفاء جدد من المعارضه
اكثر اعتدالا وهذا يناسب الامريكان واذا
رفض نتنياهو فسوف تسقط حكومته وهو
معها لانها في كل الاحوال عاجزه عن تحقيق
نصر في غزه وعاجز عن ايجاد اي تصور
لمستقبل غزه خصوصا اذا نفض الامريكان
ايديهم في هذه الحاله ستاتي حكومه اخرى من
المعارضه مستعده لقبول العرض الامريكي
لانهاء
الحرب معلومات اجناش ان نتنياهو رغم رفضه
العلل المتكرر واخر هذه
المرات اللي رفض
فيها
اي تفاوض او ابداء اي مرونه لانهاء الحرب
كان امس الاربعاء
7 فبراير
مساء لكن وفقا لمقربين من نتنياهو تحدثوا
لديفيد جنشس ان نتنياهو يعي جيدا ان
التطبيع مع السعوديين قد يكون سبيله
الوحيد امامه لغسل عار فشله في 7 اكتوبر
وفشل ودي قصه اتكلمنا عنه كتير امله
الوحيد انه يعمل انجاز ضخم الانجاز الضخم
ده انه يقول الاسرائيليين انا نجحت في ان
اطبع مع اهم دوله عربيه اسلاميه في
المنطقه
الان طيب العرض واضح جدا لنتنياهو
الامريكان ابلغوا به رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي وفقا لديفيد جناشي وهو يفكر
وربما يطيل التفكير املا في حدوث معجزه
تغنيه عن اتخاذ قرارات صعبه لكن عنصر
الوقت ليس في صالح نتنياهو ما عندوش العمر
كله يفكر فيه لان الولايات المتحده ابلغته
ان اتفاق التطبيع السعودي يجب ان يبدا
ويعني نشرع فيه بقوه خلال الشهرين
المقبلين ليه لان ولي العهد يطالب كجزء من
الاتفاق زي ما قلت لحضراتكم بضمانات شبيه
بضمانات النيتو للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ونظرا لانه العام الحالي هو عام انتخابي ف
يجب اتمام هذه القضيه وعرض الاتفاقيه
الامنيه الامريكيه السعوديه على
الكونجرس في حد اقصى يونيو المقبل لان بعد
يونيو المقبل هيكون الجميع اعضاء الكونجرس
والرئيس الامريكي كل الاحزاب مشغوله
بالانتخابات الامريكيه التي سوف تجري في
نوفمبر القادم وبالتالي هيتم اذا لم تناقش
في في يونيو المقبل هيتم تاجيل بقى النظر
فيها
الى الاداره الامريكيه المقبله اذا كان
بايدن او غيره لكن لا يمكن لاي من هذه
التصورات
المعقده ان تبدا الا بعد انتهاء القتال في
غزه والقتال لن يتوقف بدون اطلاق سراح
المحتجزين والاسرى الاسرائيليين وهؤلاء لن
يتم اطلاق سراحهم الا بتلبيه شروط حماس
ولذلك هناك مفاوضات محمومه الان يشارك
فيها الجانب الامريكي طبعا مع مسؤولين
مصريين وقطريين ل وضع الصيغه يقبلها
الطرفين وطبعا اتكلمنا عن المفاوضات دي
قبل كده وهنتكلم عنها بعد كده لكن على كل
الاحوال وفقا لمسؤولين ده ديفيد جنشس اللي
بيقول وغيره الحقيقه يعني بس انا هنا بعرض
يعني يعني ما يقوله ديفيد في هذه المقاله
انه مسؤولين كتير بيقولوا انه الصفقه
تقريبا استوت وانه خلال ساعات او ايام على
الاقص على الاكثر هيكون عندنا وقف لاطلاق
النار وانهاء للحرب طيب لاحظوا انه
الفلسطينيين هيعدوا بوقف الحرب وطبعا في
مقابل انه يطلقوا ال 136 سجين ورهين او
اسير باي تعبير بالاضافه الى جثث الاسرى
اللي قتلوا هيطلق
سراح السجناء الفلسطينيين في السجون
الاسرائيليه وهيتم وقف اطلاق النار
بالاضافه لتلبيه شروط اخرى لكن اللي هيحصل
كالاتي انه الفلسطينيين هيقولوا تم وقف
اطلاق النار ويحتفلوا بذلك يحتفلوا
بانتصارهم على الاسرائيليين اسرائيل طبعا
مش هتقول كده هتقول دي مجرد هدنه وانه
احنا ممكن الهدنه معناها ان ممكن ايه يعني
انه يوصلوا القتال فيما بعد لكن هو هيكون
وقعه ده وفقا لمصادر متعدده منها ديفيد
ديفيد اشيس هيكونوا وقعوا والتزموا بوقف
اطلاق النار بس هو نتنياهو ما يقدرش يقول
انا هوقف اطلاق النار اوقف الحرب لكن
هيقول هدنه حتى يمرر هذه
الصفقه يعني في الراي العام الاسرائيلي
اللي رافض الجزء منه اللي رافض لوقف اطلاق
النار واذا تم ذلك سوف يصبح التوصل الى
اتفاق حدودي بقى مع بين اسرائيل ولبنان
ممكنا ويمكن بدء التفاوض على اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه وقبل ذلك سوف يتحرك السعوديون
نحو التطبيع مع
اسرائيل ده هو خلاصه معلومات اللي توفرت
الى ديفيد جنشس من المسؤولين في الاداره
الامريكيه ديفيد جنشس بيختم مقاله بتعليق
مهم جدا او ملحوظه مهمه جدا خلاصتها ان
التصور الامريكي
ل حل مشاكل الشرق الاوسط او السيطره على
الازمه المتصاعده طموح جدا جدا بشكل قد
يصعب تحقيقه لاسباب متعدده اهمها ان
الرئيس الامريكي نفسه كما يصفه اجناش
بشكلا دقيق من وجهه نظري رجل يتمتع برؤيه
استراتيجيه ولكنه ضعيف سياسيا ثلاث
ملاحظات مقال ديفيد اجناش متشابه جدا مع
مضمون مقال توماس فريدمان ولان الرجلين
كلاهما من المطلعين جيدا على كواليس
السياسه في واشنطن وفي البيت الابيض
تحديدا ده بيجعل ن اكثر ثقه فيما نقلوه
عما يجري من تصورات في البيت الابيض
لاحتواء المنطقه احتواء الازمه اللي
موجوده في المنطقه اثنين التصور الامريكي
اللي عرضه ديفيد جنشس واللي عرضه توماس
فريدمان احنا تناولناه بشكل متكرر قبل ذلك
لما تكلم عن تصور بايدن لاداره منطقه
الشرق الاوسط واعرض لحضراتكم هذه الحلقات
الكلام ده اتقال قبل كده وانه هذا التصور
باختصار اللي بيقوم على فكره الجوهر منه
تطبيع السعوديه مع اسرائيل وبالتالي اعاده
تشكيل التحالفات في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
بشكل يؤدي الى عزل ايران وتقليل النفوذ
الروسي
والصيني في المنطقه الى اخره ارجعوا
للحلقات السابقه التي سوف اضع لكم رابطها
وطبعا ده بيصب في صالح بايدن الانتخابيه
يعني مصالحه الانتخابيه لانه عاوز يخرج
الى الناخبين قبل نوفمبر المقبل ويقول انا
عملت انجاز كبير جدا على الاقل لعشاق
اسرائيل في الولايات المتحده اضيف فقط الى
هذا التصور اللي هو كان قائم من الايام
الاولى لادارته فكره وقف الحرب في غزه
والتاكد من عدم اتساع الصراع بعد 7 اكتوبر
الملحوظه الثالثه ان ديفيد اشيس في ختام
مقالته محق في الامرين الامر الاول ان
اداره بايدن على مدار اربعه سنوات اثبتت
فعلا انها قادره على صياغه افكار جيده على
الورق سرعان ما تتحول لتجارب فشل على ارض
الواقع يعني مثلا كان بيخطط لضرب اسفين
بين روسيا والصين حتى يستفرد
بالصين فانتهى به الحال لحرب عسكريه مع
روسيا وحرب بارده اكثر ضراوه مع الصين
وتحالف اقوى بين روسيا
والصين كان زي ما طبعا اشرنا وسوف نشير
بيخطط الى تهدئه كامله في الشرق الاوسط
باحياء الاتفاق النووي مع ايران وفشل بشكل
ذريع رغم انه مشكوك في قدرته على تحقيق
تصوراته لكن لازم الجميع يحاول ياخذ كلامه
على محمل الجد لان البدائل محدوده
ننتقل الى كاتب ثالث مهم انا بتابعه
باهتمام وان كنت لا اثق كثيرا في ارائه
هذا الكاتب هو استاذ العلوم السياسيه
المعروف ولتر راسل ميد اللي كتب في 29
يناير الماضي مقالا بعنوان الشرق الاوسط
اسوا ازمات
بايدن ولت راسل ميد هو استاذ متخصص في
السياسه الخارجيه خصوصا للولايات المتحده
له كتب مهمه في هذا
المجال
وهو بيدرس في جامعات منها جامعه هيل
الامريكيه وبيكتب في دوريات مختلفه منها
ناشنال انترست ومنها فورن افيرز وطبعا
بيكتب في وول ستريت بانتظام لكن لما بيكتب
خارج الشرق الاوسط بتحصل منه على معلومات
جيده ولما بيكتب برض عن الشرق الاوسط
بتحصل منه على افكار
و معلومات قيمه لكنه منح حاز بشكل كبير
لاسرائيل بشكل في تقديري يقود من مصداقيته
كثيرا على كل الاحوال هدف هذه الحلقات هو
عرض افكار الجميع حتى وان كنا غير مقتنعين
بها حتى لا نكون كمن يسمعون انفسهم فقط في
هذا المقال قلت الراس الميت اللي التقى
طبعا كثير التقى ويلتقي الكثير من
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين ومنهم بنيامين
نتنياهو
نفسه قال ان الاخبار القادمه من الشرق
الاوسط لا يمكن ان تكون
اسوا اسوا مما يجري يعني على الاقل
بالنسبه لاداره بايدن ليه قال من غزه
البحر الاحمر
ا ومن الاردن الى العراق يعني كل دول
المنطقه منطقه الشرق الاوسط يعني بتصدر
موجات من الهجمات غير المبرره في تقديره
من قبل ايران
ووكلائها على القوات الامريكيه صل بيذكر
بالمفارق هذا التصعيد المؤسف لم يكن ابدا
ما تمنته اداره بايدن حين دخلت الى البيت
الابيض في يناير 2021 اذ كان احد اهم
اركان سياسه بايدن الخارجيه هو خفض التوتر
مع ايران وبالتالي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
حتى يتفرغ الى الصين
وروسيا ويخفض التوتر ازاي مع ايران
وبالتالي الشرق الاوسط من خلال احياء
الاتفاق النووي الذي خرج منه ترامب في
2018 لماذا فشل بايدن او لماذا فشلت
استراتيجيه بايدن ديفيد اشيس كان بيقول من
شويه لان الرئيس الامريكي رغم يعني قدرته
على وضع سياسات او استراتيجيات جيده لكنه
ضعيف سياسي سياسيا قلت الراس الميد عنده
تفسير اخر هو انه السبب في فشل اداره
بايدن وبالتالي التهاب منطقه الشرق الاوسط
هي ايران الشريره ايران هي التي تسيطر على
التوجه والايقاع السياسي للشرق الاوسط
وليس امريكا منذ ان جاء جو بايدن الى
البيت الابيض فراي الاستاذ الشهير الشرق
الاوسط الان يشتعل لان استراتيجيه بايدن
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط اللي كانت بتقوم
على التهدئه مع ايران فشلت وهي فشلت لان
ايران لم تكن ترغب ولم تكن مستعده لتبادل
امريكا الرغبه في تهدئه منطقه الشرق
الاوسط هذا هو رايه ورايه ده معناه كده
انه لا علاقه لاسرائيل ولا سياساتها ولا
لاحتلالها للاراضي الفلسطينيه ولا
للممارسات الامريكيه اي علاقه بما يجري
الان المشكله كلها في ايران ايران ايران
في موقع ريسبونس بالل ستيت كرافت وهو موقع
جيد وعنده كتاب جيدين جون مولر وده استاذ
في العلوم السياسيه في جامعه اوهايو
الامريكيه كتب في 5 فبراير الجاري مقالا
بعنوان بعد سلسله من التحذيرات سلكت
اسرائيل طريق 11 سبتمبر خلاصه المقال انه
كثير من الامريكان وعلى راسهم الرئيس
الامريكي حذر اسرائيل من ان ترتكب نفس
الاخطاء التي ارتكبتها امريكا بعد 11
سبتمبر واذكركم ان اسرائيل بتعتبر هجوم 7
اكتوبر زي هجوم 11 سبتمبر بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده وهي قالت كده علشان تضمن
ان الولايات المتحده كلها تنتفض وتبقى
تقدر ان هي تدعمها علشان ه يتخيلوا
انفسهم وما حدث لهم بعد 11 سبتمبر 2001
لكن الرئيس الامريكي بيقول لهم ان
الامريكان ارتكبوا اخطاء وخلاصه هذه
الاخطاء انه امريكا بالغت في الخطر الذي
شكلته القاعده بعد 11 سبتمبر وان ده خطر
وجودي وان هي ممكن يصل بها الامر ان هي
تهاجم الامريكان باسلحه
نوويه الامر الثاني انها بالغت في
الانتقام بشكل ادى الى الاضرار بالولايات
المتحده والكاتب بيتكلم عن تفاصيل كثيره
تستحق القراءه سوف اضع لكم رابطها لكن
خلاصه اللي بيقول زي ما بقول لحضراتكم انه
ده القاعده كانت بهذه القوه وان القاعده
اللي كانت محظوظه في نجاحها في 11 سبتمبر
فشلت بعد ذلك فشلا ذريعا في ان تقوم باي
شيء ذات يعني تاثير على غرار 11 سبتمبر او
حتى اقل منه وكل كل اللي عملته بعد كده
كان عباره عن فيديوهات مليئه بالصخب
والغضب لكن رد الفعل الامريكي بقى كان
كبيرا جدا بشكل ادر بالولايات المتحده على
كل المستويات لان هي علشان ترد على
القاعده خاضت حربين على الاقل بالاضافه
الى حرب شامله حربين ضد افغانستان والعراق
بالاضافه او الحربين دول كانوا في اطار
حرب كبيره اسمها الحرب على الارهاب ادت
الى نتائج كارثيه فبدل ما سقط 3000 فقط في
11 سبتمبر في الهجوم بتاع 11 سبتمبر قتل
في هذه الحرب اكث من 100 ضعف ال 3000 يعني
بتتكلم على ارقام مهوله من الجانب
الامريكي
وحلفائها يعني التقديرات بتقول انه مات
15000 جندي امريكي في الحربين دول وانتحر
3000 جندي بسبب مشاركته الماساويه في هذه
الحروب فضل عن
177000 من قوات الدول الاخرى التي تحالفت
مع امريكا في هذه الحروب وطبعا دي ارقام
مهوله ده خلاف من سقط من ابرياء من
الافغان والعراقيين
وغيرهم بيقول ان اسرائيل بتكرر نفس القصه
وبالغت جدا في الخوف من رد
فعل او من اهميه ما حدث في 7 اكتوبر ما 7
اكتوبر هو بيصف بان شيء كان مروع لكن في
رايه ان ان ان حماس في كل الاحوال او
غيرها لن تستطيع ان تتمكن من هجوم بهذه
القوه مره اخرى ده رايه هو وانه الافضل ان
اسرائيل كان يبقى رد
فعلها معتدل او منضبط وليس بهذا الشمول
الذي ادى الى
تراجع التعاطف مع اسرائيل وادى
الى بيئه عدائيه لاسرائيل
شارع منتفض ضدها ما يعني انها اسرائيل
يقينا سوف يكون لديها الكثير جدا من
الشباب العربي والمسلم اللي هم اطفال الان
العازمي على الانتقام منها بسبب تصرفاتها
في غزه وحتى الحكومات العربيه اللي كانت
راغبه في التطبيع معها عادت واصبحت تضع
القضيه الفلسطينيه على قائمه اولوياتها
وبختم بانه رد الفعل الاسرائيلي بعد 7
اكتوبر مثل رد الفعل الامريكي بعد 11
سبتمبر ليس فقط غير اخلاقي ولكنه غبي
جدا يعني اتمنى ان تكون هذه الجوله
السريعه في اهم احداث هذا الاسبوع قد لاقت
قبلكم والقاكم الاسبوع المقبل على خير
باذن الله اشكركم والى اللقاء